ستمتد الحرب شهورا طويله وتكلفتها اكبر
بكثير مما كان مخططا هذا ما قاله نتنياهو
في جلسه صاخبه للحكومه الاسرائيليه عقدت
لمناقشه ميزانيه العام الجديد بعد مرور م
يوم على بدء الحرب وسط خلافات حاده بل
وتوبيخ نتنياهو لوزراء بارزين مثل بنفير
بعد تهديدهم بانهم لن يوافقوا على اقرار
الميزانيه
ولا يتشابه كلام نتنياهو في جلسه الحكومه
تلك مع كلامه في مؤتمره في اليوم السابق
فحسب بل ان شحوب وجهه كان نفسه حين كرر
تعهده بمواصله القتال واكد وعوده الثلاثه
التي دقت طبول الحرب الاسرائيليه على
وقعها اعاده المختطفين تدمير حماس وضمان
ان لا يخرج من غزه اي تهديد بعد
اليوم لكن هذا اليوم لازال يبدو بعيدا على
الاقل من وجهه نظر الاسرائيليين الذين ما
عادت عباره اليوم التالي عنوانا ثابتا في
صحفهم واعلامهم لتحل محلها تدريجيا عناوين
اخرى اقل تفاؤلا فيوم واحد بعد خطاب
نتنياهو اي في اليوم المئه للحرب تصدرت
رؤوس الصحف التي طالما روجت للحرب ودعت
لاستمرارها حتى النهايه عناوين يشتم منها
كل شيء سوى الروح القتاليه العاليه التي
حاول نتنياهو بثها فقد برز في صحيفه يدعوت
احرونوت واسعه الانش والتاثير عنوان هو
يتزايد الشعور بان نتنياهو يمدد الحرب
لاسباب شخصيه وفي مقاله في الصحيفه نفسها
راى الكاتب وهو خبير اسرائيلي في السياسات
والشؤون الاستراتيجيه ان التوصل لصفقه مع
وقف الحرب كليا هو احد الخيارات التي لا
مفر منها والا ستكون خشيه من حرب استنزاف
لن تخرج منها اسرائيل منتصره اما معاريف
فاور دت خبرا نقلا عن لواء في سلاح الجو
قال فيه ان التصور بانه بالامكان حسم حرب
من خلال التفوق الجوي هو تصور يجب ان
يتغير كما اجرت نفس الصحيفه استطلاعا كان
سؤاله هل توافقون على عقد صفقه لتحرير
المختطفين حتى لو كان الثمن انهاء الحرب
وبغض النظر عن نتيجه الاستطلاع فمجرد طرح
التساؤل يشي بان انتهاء الحرب لا بل
انهائها دون تحقق اهدافها المعلنه بات
خيارا فرض نفسه على النقاش الداخلي
الاسرائيلي اما موقع والله الاخباري فورد
خبرا يتحدث عن الدعم الامريكي عنوانه انه
بعد 100 يوم من الحرب بدا صبر رئيس بايدن
ينفد والوضع غدا كارثيا وفي حين يبدو
المشهد كذلك في التيار المركزي في المشهد
الاعلامي الاسرائيلي تظل هناك اصوات من
تيار اليمين تعزف عزف البنادق تنتقي
الاخبار والتصريحات التي ما زالت تر في
استمرار القصف ونشر الدمار الوسيله
الوحيده لاعاده الاسرى الاسرائيليين
فموقع 04 المعروف بانحيازه اليميني يركز
كالعاده على ان يكون منصه لبنغ فير رغم ان
الاخير لا ينزل عن منصه الا وقد اثار
عاصفه من تصريحات الاستنكار داخليا
وخارجيا فينقل الموقع اليوم تصريحاته
الناقده لاعضاء مجلس الحرب المصغر بعد
اعلان الانتقال لمرحله اقل حده من القتال
وحتى بخصوص قضيه المختطفين العامل الاكثر
ضغطا على حكومه نتنياهو لوقف مح ممل
للقتال فيها ينقل تصريحا لوالد احد الاسرى
يقول فيه ان الضربات الثقيله لحماس هي ما
سينهي الحرب ويعيل المختطفين صوت يبدو
شاذا في وسط عائلات المختطفين الذين
تتعالى اصواتهم غضبا وسخطا مطالبين
باستقاله الحكومه وعوده المختطفين حتى لو
كان الثمن بقاء
حماس في مؤتمره الاخير استعمل نتنياهو
كعادته اقتباسا من التوراه حاول فيه شحن
الهمم ورفع الم
ف يخاطب الله الامه اليهوديه التي جمعها
من اقطار الارض ومنحها ارض اسرائيل
فقال
ا واسوا ارضكم التي منحتها لعبدي يعقوب
واسكنها بامان وابنوا فيها البيوت وازرعوا
الكروم واذا ظن نتنياهو ان كلامه التوراتي
الداعيه لاستمرار الحرب بحر من المداد لا
ينفد فصبر الاسرائيلين كما يبدو اخذ في
التلاشي فوق صوت طبول الح
باتت تطغى صرخات الغضب من ضحايا الحرب
الذين غدا صمت ابنائهم المحتجزين في غزه
هو كل ما يتردد صداه في اذانهم